[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am merely
mark ellis and i'm thrilled to have
jacqueline coley my co-host on the show
with shoes every week not just because
she's great but because jacqueline gets
to talk to goats man jacqueline
you just interviewed the williams
sisters and oh by the way will smith was
there too yeah it is not a bad sunday if
you're gonna work on a sunday talking to
the two greatest tennis players to ever
grace this planet is not a bad way to go
and they were lovely it was such a great
opportunity i am so grateful to the
folks at warner brothers because they
are executive producers of the new film
king richard which we will not have to
be finding out if is rotten tomatoes
wrong about because it is
totally beloved by everyone that's seen
it so far it's a great film and they
were so lovely to talk to oh i want it
to be good yeah it's really good and and
mark literally mark likes me ladies and
gentlemen but he never texts me as
quickly as he did after he saw that post
like well i didn't every time i couldn't
because because i saw it on a sunday and
i also saw what happened to your
football team on sunday so i wanted to
let you be in your own space and i
thought maybe you set up that interview
just because you knew what was gonna
happen but that's a conversation for a
different day if we're talking about the
greatest of all time in a sport i would
say venus is the greatest tennis player
excuse me serena's the greatest tennis
player ever lived but venus is way up
there and if you're looking at shark
movies jacqueline then maybe serena
williams if she's the jaws yeah
i will get there then maybe venus is the
deep blue sea
of tennis players because that's the
movie we're talking about today that's
the point of this diatribe is that deep
blue sea is our movie and we have a very
special guest who stars in the film is
dr susan mcallister saffron burroughs is
going to be joining us here in just a
little bit deep blue sea came out 1999
and it's rotten it's it's that rotten
movie where it's like spaceballs it just
needs a few more reviews to be fresh
it's 59
on the tomato meter and even more
curious is the 39 rotten audience score
i don't get that at all because well
we'll we'll talk about our feelings
about the movie when saffron joins us
but um
jacqueline if if you want to tell us
what deep blue sea is about i guess now
would be the time to do it i know
there's sharks anything else we need to
know i mean that's pretty much it but i
will go ahead and give us a quick
breakdown so deep blue c is the story of
the genetically modified mako sharks
which are being genetically engineered
by this pharmaceutical company out in
the middle of the ocean and essentially
what it is is saffron burrow's character
she's a doctor who is hell bent on
trying to find a cure for alzheimer's it
is something that she holds near and
dear to her heart samuel l jackson's
company is funding her endeavors and
they have been getting a ton of bad
press because a couple of the sharps
sharks has escaped and along for the
ride to sort of wrangle these sharks
they have their shark wrangler played by
thomas jane and an entire ensemble cast
of both doctors researchers
and also their chef preacher played by
ll cool j and needless yeah needless to
say you can't have a shark movie without
the uh likelihood that the sharks may
escape and essentially where these guys
are located at is slowly sinking after a
horrific plane crash because they've
been told if they can't get these sharks
to be harvested they're about to shut
everything down revelations come out
that make us realize that these sharks
are smarter than the raptors
in jurassic world jurassic park and they
are coming for the humans as they try to
find a way to make it to the surface and
escape and we sort of follow them along
their
underwater adventure of trying not to
get eaten by sharks llc is there for his
great quips lots of people get eaten and
uh chomps jane is wet along with
everyone else for most of the story so
win in my book uh it's a huge win on
multiple fronts and it's a win for the
audience here even if you haven't seen
deep blue sea look i'm going to tell you
to pause this and go watch it and i
might say that again later but like you
can listen to our conversations we're
going to spoil everything we're going to
talk about the big surprise scenes and
oh my god i can't believe that happened
we're going to get in into this with
saffron burrows but i think you can
listen to it and then you can go watch
deeply sleek late and still have a great
time watching it i'm just saying there's
a whole lot of carnage to enjoy so
without further ado we're going to go to
tim ryan who's our expert review
creation manager here at rotten tomatoes
tim is going to be telling us what the
critics were saying about this movie way
back
in 1999 when it was released that summer
so tim
have at it
[Music]
when it comes to shark tastic
entertainment nearly everyone can agree
that if jaws represents the pinnacle of
the form and if sharknado is the
subgenre at its campist then deep blue
sea is smack dab in the middle and the
middle is where the critics found
themselves as well some enjoyed it as a
fun action flick with a sense of humor
while others derided it as a
substance-free knockoff of other better
monster movies deep blue sea is rotten
at 59 with 113 reviews and it has a 39
audience score
so what did the critics have to say
in a rotten review keith phipps of the
av club wrote deep blue sea a sort of
cross between aliens without the thrills
and the poseidon adventure without the
camp compensations
doesn't deliver the killer shark versus
a-list character actor thrills you crave
in a fresh review david sterett of the
christian science monitor wrote it's
just the thing for moviegoers wanting
violent adventure split-second editing
and enough water-drenched cinematography
to make titanic look parched the rotten
tomatoes critic's consensus reads deep
blue sea is no jaws but action fans
seeking some toothy action can certainly
do and almost certainly have done far
worse for b-movie thrills
so that's deep blue c and if you're
interested in a movie that's this
movie's exact opposite in every way i
suggest the deep blue sea starring
rachel vice in a certified fresh drama
with zero sharks and a whole lot of
heartbreak back to you folks
well thank you for that alternative to
the shark movie with the deep blue sea
tim i look it's easy to monday morning
quarterback these these things
especially when it's you know over 20
years later but
can't we just have some fun with some
sharks we're about to have some fun
right now with our special guest let's
bring on the one the only saffron
burrows
[Music]
and as promised the star of deep blue
sea saffron burrows is joining us not
just that you can currently capture in
season three of the hit netflix show you
stage screen you recently played jackie
kennedy at the annenberg center for the
performing arts you've done it all
saffron but now we get to sort of look
at your career full circle and go back
to that sweet sweet shark movie that is
somehow
not quite fresh on the tomato meter
first of all thank you so much for
joining the show
thank you so much for having me i i want
to start with the question that
everybody gets asked when they join the
show because it's called rotten tomatoes
is wrong so it's 59 rotten on the tomato
meter and it's 39 rotten audience score
saffron is rotten tomatoes wrong about
deep blue sea so i could make a case for
it
um having having having re-watched it
recently
i was impressed with the uh i was
impressed with the pace of it from the
start i watched it with a friend
yesterday and who hadn't really seen it
and
they were
you know in the first 10 minutes a lot
happened and you meet these characters i
love the ensemble nature of it obviously
there's wonderful actors there
some last longer than others on screen
um
but the pace of it is it's i think that
holds up that stands the test over time
and also the
i i mean i love the film where you in
the first 20 minutes get to know people
you get little snippets of people's
lives and histories and there's a life
they create there you know obviously
there's a community that is really
enjoyable um
and the first act of cure violence
doesn't happen immediately so
you're kind of in this kind of glorious
just
here we are meeting people thing and
then boom
so i was i was pleased that it it seems
to stand up uh it was made quite a while
ago
and it's
it's kind of it's pretty exciting still
i think
there's some things that surprise me
watching it again um
there's quite a bit of religion there
from ellen called jay's character
and by the end he has us all
pretty much you know praying for our
lives
but
yeah there's some there's some things
that stand up uh
i was curious to see you know a lot of
films from 20 or 30 years ago have a
sort of inbuilt sexism that just wasn't
questioned then
and uh
things i loved as a kid i i look at now
wow that was
pretty full of stereotypes you know i
think they try to avoid too many of
those in this
i'd love your thoughts what do you think
i i mean i'll i'll leave it to
jacqueline first but we we did mention
in our in in our little pre-show warm-up
when jack and i were talking to the
audience that jacqueline and i love to
talk about the movie in depth and so our
audience knows that we're probably going
to be spoiling it but we should we're
reiterating that right now that we are
going to spoil the movie deep blue sea
and all of the fun surprises and all
that stuff that happens in it so if you
haven't seen deep blue sea yet again
maybe you want to pause this and then go
check it out and then come on back
jaclyn it's 59
sounds like saffron thinks it should be
fresh how about you
yeah i mean it's almost fresh and it's
one of those weird ones too where it has
it has an audience to it but the
audience score i don't think reflects it
because it is just this gooey camp
goodness and also a really like taught
thriller too it mashes up a lot i think
together but i think saffron touched on
it the opening
look everyone goes into this movie
thinking that it's going to be some
either page from
whatever of jaws like you that's the
ultimate shark movie and by having that
opening they're like okay double the fun
we're going to get two couples but they
subvert the opening of jaws where the
girl dies and they actually get saved
and you have
thomas jane pop in as like the ultimate
yeah the ultimate hero the one thing i
will say to it is look
i had not fully seen this movie until we
were getting ready for this i've seen
most of it like through clips but this
is the first time i really sat down
watched the whole thing and the only
thing i have to say is the that colin
trevorrow owes the entire jurassic world
to this movie because jurassic world is
deep blue sea you uh saffron is the
bryce dallas howard character tom jade
is the chris pratt character they ripped
off this movie for a billion dollars and
i say that i would love i literally was
like this is jurassic world this is
jurassic world wow i don't remember the
first time i saw it i remember renting
the movie i didn't get a chance to see
it in movie theaters when it came out in
1999 and you all opened against some
stiff competition i mean you still had
blair witch project in theaters probably
the phantom menace in the matrix were on
their last legs but you had this little
horror movie called the sixth sense that
was coming out around that time too and
so it was a lot of competition so i
rented it but i i literally do remember
sitting in my living room at my at my my
parents place and standing up in shock
when that moment with the shark jumping
out and just chomping samuel l jackson
and it's like
what the hell just happened it was one
of the coolest moments i've ever seen in
a movie because like you said the pacing
up to that point
it's it's so it never feels rushed but
it's just it just moves it's such it's
the john wooden ucla basketball coach
quote be quick but never hurry it moves
it moves it moves but we do get some
time to know
our characters and so as i guess my
first question before we get into like
the the scenes that that still speak to
you your experience when you're making
the movie because it's directed by renny
harwin he he was coming off a a
disastrous run with uh with with
cutthroat island you know he had some
nice hits leading up to cutthroat island
and then that happened and i'm sure was
just such a a tough break for him in his
career so he's trying to rebound with
deep blue sea there's a lot of moving
parts there's a lot of people there's
mechanical sharks what was it like for
you as the lead of a film like that when
you were making it well it was it was
quite a shift i i was in london and
rennie had seen me and something um
maybe audition for something else and
they said
they loved he'd love to meet you and
they the studio loved me
so they flew me to la just for the
meeting um meanwhile i had some kind of
surreal cliched la experience as soon as
i landed some dodgy guy in my hotel
invited me to go bareback riding on the
beach which you know like every every
cliche took place the moment i landed
and it was i was you know i went to
school in
hackney and i was from like a strong
community of
socialists and feminists and activists
and i suddenly there were these surreal
kind of sunset boulevardi things
occurring but i was very drawn to when i
went to meet um akiba goldsman and reni
and akiva's the creator and and he
wrote films like a beautiful mind he was
a beautiful writer um and then they told
me in the room that sam jackson and
stella skarsgard had already committed
to the film
and they would you know
probably the two actors on screen that i
held in
the highest esteem at that time and and
pretty much still do you know so
having those two fine fine people in it
already was just thrilling you know to
have to sort of
tell a story like this which is
obviously intended for a wide audience
and then tell it with really fine actors
and then the ensemble they gathered i
just remember coming away from the
meeting thinking my goodness that i want
to work with those people you know aida
totoro and jackie mckenzie and mike
rappaport and ll cool j who was my hero
when i was 11 had his poster on my wall
um
it was a beautiful ensemble and i don't
i think that's unusual for a sort of an
action thriller
movie to have such a such a cast so that
was my my main impression was i came and
met them and
they told me who was in it and i
remember showing up in my kind of little
leather shoes and my
cardigan and i read
the scene for everybody and then they
said oh my goodness we have to scrub you
up so they you know put me through this
kind of machine of
clothes and hair and makeup i was
i'd never really been i'd never been in
a film like that before you know where
they sort of present you to the studio
and say
here she is with a bit of powder on
because i i just turned up in my
cardigan literally and um it was quite
funny the process of preparing oneself
for such a role
for thomas jane and i especially because
we just had to do
uh
quite a bit of physical labor you know
it was it was
six months of
six days a week
you know wake up
there there's a kind of a little ritual
i told my kids they think it's just
while
you you know when we shot down in mexico
you wake up
they had a tanning bed in there that
they had for leo dicaprio for titanic um
so you had to do
workout turning bed hair makeup all by
you know 5 30 a.m or something so it was
like this little boot camp for thomas
and i yeah it was like a little military
operation because because i did read uh
jacqueline this was one of my favorite
parts about the the research that
hoffmeier puts together for us is that
you all shot in the same huge water tank
that james cameron had built for titanic
and so it was a lot of those sets except
this time you have the benefit of every
performer's dream with a bunch of
mechanical sharks swimming around there
too
so
being in being in that tank with the
sharks
are the sharks realistic enough that
you're actually afraid of them on set
were you friends with the mechanical
sharks were they better behaved than the
one bruce from jaws i mean
what's it like being in a tank with
sharks they i mean you were warned not
to
not to sort of break protocol because
they were
ironically these mechanism shots were
pretty dangerous they could move fast
yeah and if you got in the way of them
it wasn't a good idea so
it was that itself was a little bit
perilous just they were on these tracks
obviously rushing through the water in
certain shapes and
you know choreographed designs but
they were this huge metal robotic
machines that could you know you could
fall into their path and
that would be a bad way to go with a
mechanical shot taking you down so
there were there we
were filming in these tanks with which
they created for titanic and it was
built to look as if you're in in the
middle of the pacific not obviously just
at the edge of the pacific
on baja california just off the coast
and um it was sea water so it was pretty
cold it was literally just fresh sea
water and then they felt for us because
we were cold so they built a sort of
huge hot tub adjacent to the tanks so
between setups there'd be lighting stuff
we'd all jump into this hot tub and warm
up then get back into this very cold sea
water
i was just gonna say um what i've
learned from watching behind the scenes
of abyss and also of jaws is forget
about animals forget about you know any
other kind of things on set children
water is literally water world the abyss
jaws they all talk about how difficult
it is to film with that as a medium
because of how unpredictable it is and
how it messes everything up but it seems
with this movie they kind of got it
right because like the joke on jaws is
they called it flaws because the shark
didn't move like half of the brilliance
of jaws was because
they couldn't get the shark to move very
well and so they kind of had to like
pull it in certain ways so the reason
why you never see the shark is because
they couldn't get the shark on screen
but these sharks are fairly visible and
it's not just all cgi so i'm guessing
they kind of got them very functional
for y'all's filming
they did i think at the time other shark
experts said that we did good sharks
the little bit i know about shots um i
was supposed to swim with sharks the way
thomas jane does um i'm officially not
allowed to scuba dive so that didn't
happen i was quite relieved
thomas is down there you know with
swimming with sharks with just a you
know some metal between them but
i was told our shocks were pretty pretty
good i heard i read an interview with
some marine biologists that said that
mako the look of the makos was accurate
to a real mako shark and it's also the
wise choice to make these antagonists to
be the smartest shark that is in the
water which is makos and then obviously
the genetic engineering thanks to
someone like you in the movie sort of
enhances that even further but the last
thing i want to ask you before we
actually get into all of our favorite
scenes because there's so many to choose
from is that one of the i i read a story
about a test screening that went great
but not necessarily for your character
that there was a test screening and the
fans loved it but the only issue was
that the fans said well we're not sure
that saffron's character should make it
out of this movie
so they like you had to go back to die
like this is ridiculous like they
literally were like she has to die how
did you feel when you get that phone
call to be like okay
the first so the first inkling i got
that it was not gonna go in in my
character's direction was this test
screening in new york it was actually
sort of an audience
it was a public audience and they were
shouting at the screen
expletive expletive explained to die
you know asterisk
every time i showed up and uh
wow i i thought i was playing this
altruistic rather fantastic person who
was doing this groundbreaking research
um and then when sam jackson came on
this woman shouted out like i wanted to
see what she shouted it was very sexy
and very admiring and um so i realized
quickly who was who were the baddies and
i naively you know when you're when
you're young and you're playing someone
and you
you
want to
believe in their goodness you know so
this this screening in times square was
quite shocking for me they literally
were booing at me as i would pop up on
screen so i did understand why they'd
made this change
originally we shot the scene where
an uncle j thomas jane and i survived
and we were in a lifeboat and benny
harlan was in a helicopter above us with
a camera and we had walkie-talkies and
at a certain moment we spot a ship a
huge
ocean liner that rescues us
um
the the boys with me got seasick so they
took uh
you know
anti-anti-queasy medicine it made them
very sleepy so we were in this little
blow-up boat with the walkie-talkie and
obviously you know it was hidden beneath
us and someone would call out action
and i think both the boys thomas and ll
were almost napping because they were so
sleepy from this medicine so we're in
this tiny rubber dinghy and i'm kicking
action action and um we do the sequence
and uh
rennie loves renee harlan loves the
loudspeaker a loud halo so he even if
he's not in a helicopter he you know
on a set like this in a shoot like this
you sort of need a bit of you know you
need some volume
so he he liked to call me steve cat
because that was he called me street cat
because that was my rap name when i was
a kid so he found out that i was a
rapper and i was street cat and my
friend was street dog so he goes
okay street cat go for it and then he'd
talk you through the scene and
so i was street cat for the whole shoot
so there was this rescue scene that we
shot and then yeah i got this phone call
saying
um we don't feel
um that you should be surviving this so
we've had to go ahead actually and shoot
a quick moment with the body double in a
pool in l.a because um we had to do it
fast and you're in london so oh wow
that's what we've done
oh yeah
it's it's almost like you as saffron
burrows were going through the same
thing that your character was because
you thought you were doing good in the
movie but then it turns out that not
everyone felt the same way about it
so you know what's funny though it is a
testament to your acting because i get
the altruism but i think it was that
full force altruism and in the wake of
the destruction that people couldn't
deal with you know what i'm saying like
it wasn't i think that they dislike you
it was just more like there were so many
characters that perished
yeah they just had to like that like
she's gotta get it too like everybody's
gone through it the bird died
yeah
the bird didn't have anything to do with
it
and i see now i watch it again think wow
she's focused in a way that's that's
alarming for all the other humans on
board
there's a there's a blinkered focus
that's
a bit concerning yes
yeah the bird
the poor bird yeah you never kill the
dog in the movie but the birds 50 50 at
best so i i want to get into some of the
scenes that we all love from the movie
because we all obviously i i also think
that rotten tomatoes is wrong it's one
of these movies that is right on that
line of demarcation it's 59 if it was 60
it'd be fresh and so i think it deserves
to be even higher than that simply
because the task at hand it's like
everybody knows that jaws is the shark
movie so how do you do one that
separates itself from jaws one of the
ways that this does it is you have the
surprises like when stellen gets his arm
bit off for when sam jackson gets
completely bit in in a hole um but
my one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is that that horror like setup
where
thomas jane's character has to swim and
he's got to go take care of some stuff
but then the sharks are smart enough to
start turning the lights on and off and
turning the cameras on and off and it
just becomes this like haunted house
even paranormal activity type thing
where we don't really know who to trust
but we realize that the sharks are just
as smart if not smarter than us i mean i
watched the movie again this week and it
just i got chills during that scene all
over again it was just so much fun to
watch and i imagine seeing that in the
theater it's just it's just got to be
torturous in the most fun way possible
tell me i didn't see that
they recognized that gun it's impossible
sharks do not swim backwards they can't
try to stay focused
we lost picture in gen 2 pen
okay hold on
yeah i think that's true those those
moments where they create
the notion that they're actually also
they are organizing collectively yeah
against humans
that's really something when when when
he's in um when he's in that tunnel and
and it becomes clear they're attacking
simultaneously and this sort of metal
tunnel he's swimming through
um i think those moments are fantastic
and i'd forgotten how
the notion of them planning together
and in some ways sort of freaking the
humans out and then also
recognizing a garden and swimming away
from us swimming backwards all those all
those incremental buildups they have
i think
very smart because you
you know you assume sharks just go for
blood
but they're plotting
yeah it's like you're it's like your
jurassic world raptors jaclyn
yeah
it is very much like that abdominis rex
like like it is it is right there again
colin trevorrow i i feel that renny has
a very good copyright case
because the blueprint is there
absolutely for sure
i i don't know i guess if we're going to
talk about scenes real quick and this is
not just because i love him but like
they really gave ll cool j the hero's
arc of this because like first of all
the fact that he was the cook um his
name is preacher he's a man of faith
literally in every aspect of this you
instantly want him to succeed the minute
you see him talking
to his parrot and the parrot's like
eating the frosting off of his finger
like you immediately i'm like this dude
better make it and the scene with him in
the oven
as unbelievable as all of that is it's
absolutely ridiculous i was so
so there with him in that moment and
that's the reason why no matter what
even the idea that every other person
when they get in the in the mouth of the
shark is eaten instantly
but for some reason ll cool j like makes
it in and then makes it out like i i
don't know how they made that decision
that he had to live but
i was i i was very worried because i
didn't remember who lived or died in
this and then the minute i saw him like
get grabbed by the shark i was like no
i was like legitimately upset so yeah
everything llc did but especially the
him breaking out of the oven scene and
then roasting the shark for all he was
worth is a faith
the other scene is brilliant
yeah even though you know it's pretty
incongruous you completely are there
with him um i agree
he i feel he's the eyes of us of the
audience not my character he's the eyes
of the audience and
he's so human and also he's a civilian
he hasn't caused any of this trouble
he's he's the chef so
he's completely innocent in the whole
situation and
i love that he survived but i had the
same feeling i thought wait a minute
doesn't he survive and then he's got his
crucifix out and he's
yeah it was very horrible i mean yeah he
and and and he has so many scenes where
again you're just on the edge of your
seat watching it for you
saffron when when you go back and and
watch deep blue sea again or or maybe
the first time you got to see the
finished film at the premiere what was
the scene that really stuck out to you
as far as either something that you
genuinely enjoyed watching this as a fan
or the one that really got to rise out
of the audience well i i love ll cool
j's journey because i think we do see
everything through his eyes um a woman i
was at a screening last night for
belfast and a woman came up afterwards
and said why don't we get to find out
how he makes the perfect omelet um when
are we gonna discover that
hello
my name is sherman dudley
and if this message finds you then i did
not survive so this is my legacy
i have loved the pulpit and i'd love the
bottom
i did my best to be a good husband
a father
became a warranty
so what do i have to say to you
what mark do i have to leave behind
we will begin with the perfect omelette
which is made with two eggs not three
amateurs often add milk for density this
is a mistake so i love that stuff i mean
particularly memorable in terms of
filming with um when we're trying to
strap stellar skarsgard to the sort of
gurney and get him onto the helicopter
and this huge waves are spilling over us
i actually got knocked under that night
the guy who was timing the waves
i guess look the other way so
he had these dumb tanks of waters it's
funny because these things are
incredibly sophisticated in many ways
and some of it comes down to just a guy
with a cigarette who's dumping tanks of
water on you so um just the timing went
a little bit wrong and i got knocked
under and ready thought i was doing this
marvelous sort of
underwater acting stuff and i i whacked
my head on the metal um
sort of pier the jetty that we were
walking on and uh
one of the actors pulled me out samuel
jackson pulled me out and um renly
didn't realize that it was not entirely
just me improvising fantastically
um so they were they were kind of these
you know
physical moments on set i'm sure for all
of us for every actor and i'm sure for
every stunt person
where you feel the elements and what
jacqueline was saying earlier about
working with water
where you really feel it you know that
moment where ll's in the corridor and
that water just breaks forth and he's
i mean most of that you know all
of that we did either us or a very stunt
person
was there doing it the thomas jane stuff
is wild you know when we're when we're
leaving the laboratory and the water's
sort of chasing us up the stairs and
he's
crashing around and sliding around i
think
god this guy's really
you know he really went for it in an
impressive way he is what every guy
wants to look like when they get out of
the pool because he's got like 30 shots
in this movie where he's just got that
like he's just coming out of the water
and he's just like
abs and just pecs for days and we're all
yeah that's the guy that's who you take
me to the doctor you take me to whatever
person can just make me over that's who
i want to look like eventually and he
gets a little bit of a hero journey in
here too but it really is i mean again
re-watching it it's l.l cool j's movie
so big shout out to l cool j not just
for surviving both this and halloween
h2o which is both miracles but he also
have you have you heard or have you seen
the lyrics for his deepest blue sea
uh
tune that he did it's so good jacqueline
do you have a favorite quote from deep
blues from deepest blue sea well first
of all they kept the um the religious
imagery overthrew the song and like the
second verse is our father who out in
heaven hallowed be thy name killers
swarmed to beast swallowed them in
flames like seriously though
bars
straight
bars i love it wow
yeah he kind of turns into the like now
he's telling the story from the
perspective of the shark it's really i
highly encourage everybody to
to not only check that out but also as
far as deep blue sea and i do have a
question that our researcher mark
hoffmeier wanted me to ask you because
he's watched this movie more times than
any other human or shark on earth and
he wants to know if you have any insight
as to
he wanted to know why was ronnie cox
cast in the movie but didn't have any
lines
because ronnie cox from beverly hills
cop and robocop he was he's in the movie
and he lends that presence to it but
mark hoffmeyer was confused as to why he
didn't have any lines in the film i
remember him having lines when we shot
it
i remember
enough said
yeah i remember a conversation but now
now i've had i've dipped my toes into
the directing world i see now how
how
every moment
needs to earn its keep
and not not because an act is not
brilliant but just
because the narrative needs to push
forward and push forward so i and now i
understand a little more if i do have
something cut that i've performed
okay i see why the story didn't need
that so anyway that's perhaps
lends itself to an explanation but yes
can i go back to ll on the wrapping
because
because
his track i need love i don't remember i
need love so everyone in my school was
just singing that rap when it came out
is it under the under this bed you know
that one so um
so in the evenings jackie mckenzie who's
brilliant actor from australia she's a
really good cook
so we all lived together in this sort of
compound in about 20 minutes from studio
in mexico and uh so jackie would cook i
don't know what was i doing maybe making
salad or something and ll would sit at
the table and just write lyrics and i
thought this is heaven that was like
just a tuesday evening it would happen
all the time because we we only had us
you know that was our whole community
was just us
and stellan actually stella starscott
had you know his many children and his
wife with him so that was fun too
because it was like a sort of real
family feeling wait the rest of us were
sort of are you saying
alexander skarsgard was on set and bill
skarsgard was on set of deep lucy oh yes
they were
they were like little kids you know
bobbing in and out of the sea and
yeah
who would have thought that one day that
would grow to be pennywise next door to
me and he loved to play rap at three in
the morning
listen i'm a woman i'm in makeup in a
minute and you're you've gone to bed yet
so we have he was so sweet because when
he apologizes he's adorable so i'll be
knocking on his door in the middle of
night like listen i need i need to sleep
for my little three hours before i go
into the works this kind of military
operation that i have ahead of me so we
had this strange kind of college-like
atmosphere with everyone living in these
apartments next to each other you got to
be so so busy with all the projects
you're working on right now and being a
mom on top of it do you ever get to
catch up with any of the other cast from
deep blue sea have you have you ran into
ll cool j recently
i haven't seen ll for a long time i see
stellan sometimes and jackie
and um
and sam samuel yeah i'd love i'd love a
reunion that would be really good
well regardless of what the critics said
or the audience score there's two things
you could take from the film two of the
best reviews about it came from roger
ebert the incomparable iconic uh
critic gave it like a rave review and
and also because it has so many horror
elements not a bad person to like it was
a mr stephen king
so i i would just say if your fan club
is maybe a little bit different than
what people expected the movie made
money uh it's memorable you still have
people literally last night coming up to
you talking about you know things from
it i think i think you can rest in that
assumption and it's funny you mentioned
the um
the fact that you dipped your toes into
directing because your film actually
premiered in my home city the austin
film festival uh yeah um do you want to
tell us a little bit about that because
i'm curious you know you've done so many
things does directing really sort of
scratch and itch you're anxious to keep
doing or how do you feel about it now
having having tip dipped your toe into
this this pool yes thank you for that
lovely question i i was thinking about
it for quite a while
and
then a friend came to me she'd written
this piece of work called everything i
ever wanted to tell my daughter about
men and it's a woman it's it's quite
dark it's a woman who was abused as a
kid and then it's her relationships with
men that took place subsequently some
are funny some are not so funny um and i
directed two of short films within the
feature
so um
i was very fortunate because i got to
offer roles to actors that i know and
love and so jason isaacs did did one of
my shorts with me that went to austin um
and he's a brilliant actor you you guys
have probably spoken to and um
and then i was i i just
because this project was for charity it
was to support survivors of violence and
abuse people just said yes to it which
was really a treat so i asked sia to do
some music for me and write a song for
it and
went to record with her what a beautiful
experience so i i had this fantastic
time just on these shorts and now i'm
there now there's some longer projects
that i'm involved with i'm producing one
for a friend of mine she directed the
first feature by a black british woman
30 years ago um then it's i'm i that's
actually my first film that i was in as
a teenager
um
and so now she's come full circle like
she's raised kids and now she's going
back to that world of directing so i'm
producing something she's written and
directs things brilliant about racism in
los angeles and i'm directing myself for
the couple of other projects i really
like that i'm attached to
i was reminded last week i directed
marianne john baptiste in a short film
she was brilliant and she turned up and
just played this role and i was in
heaven so i was reminded just last week
how much i love it it's even more of an
honor than that you're here on our show
because you sound busy like
the fact that you had the time to come
and talk to us about deep blue sea it
just i mean i i feel like a great award
has been bestowed upon me first of all
if if if there's only one person that
you follow on the fourth of july make it
jason isaacs because he always tweets
some joke about his rey's role in the
patriot which is hilarious um but then
uh saffron you also you're you're in
season three of you which is which is
this this monster hit on netflix
and without i guess spoiling the arc too
much of what happens in season three
what can you tell us about your
character in that show yes i play uh a
role i'm reprising from season two i'm
the mother of love quinn played by
victoria pedrosi i play dottie her
mother and um
i guess in season two
you learn a little bit about this world
that love quinn's come from which is
sort of a wealthy hippy world a little
like the characters on white lotus when
i watched that it it reminded me of a
bit of the quinn's sort of privileged
but pseudo
pseudo-hippie privilege
and so
in season two you learn a little bit
about dottie and the husband and the
wealth and also the fact that they cover
up violence that her daughter's
committed or without giving too much to
way and then in season three um i'm
divorced and i'm in the middle of a
breakdown and you know the beautiful boy
who's who's died the character's son has
died and so i've got nothing to lose but
i do also think dottie quinn believes
that her tiny baby grandson is this
reincarnation of her
of her son yeah so
i understand grief you know grief
takes you in lots of different
directions so um
what's lovely about the role they've
written is she's got nothing left to
lose really except just just a couple of
things she still can hold on to and care
about
um so that's sort of what you see it's a
little bit of a tennessee williams
character you see her unraveling i i
watched season three um about a couple
like basically i had it in my preview
center and i started it and i finished
it a couple weeks ago and the thing i it
struck me about it which is that we've
seen mothers like dottie before um
somewhat narcissistic controlling and
not necessarily
that they don't it's not that they don't
love their daughters it's just their
love comes with a cost and there's
always like a transactional nature to it
but what i found interesting about
dottie is so many often times with these
characters they try to redeem them they
try to like you know in lady bird that
mom ends up being a good mom by the end
and i think although dottie has moments
of truth and and moments where she puts
it herself out there to say to love what
she needs to do i really liked how they
did not try to make her into some
you know
misunderstood mother and she just lived
in her truth of like you know not all
moms are gonna have their you know
i would say a sitcom happy ending and
this show was okay with living with the
fact that like no she's not a horrible
person but she's also not the best mom
for this particular person i'm curious
how you felt about being able to portray
a character like that because again not
irredeemable but they don't try to
redeem her either
love i love that they don't try to
redeem her
the fact she survives so many people
don't survive that show i love i love
that she survives and i love that the
baby um
heads in the direction of safety um and
they've cast it really well you know
there's some fantastic actors in this
this season and
there's some surprising
there's a lot of surprises but there's a
there's an exploration of silicon valley
and wealth and privilege and all of
those things but she she's utterly it
she it seems that this character is
utterly truthful all of the time
and
and lives by her own
personal moral compass
and some of it skewed but also she's
been surviving in a world where
the only way when she was a kid to get
by was you know i worked out a whole
background for her of course
and she
came from a rough place and had a
difficult start and then
married into something that was safety
so she she she got stitched up early on
i think and so
playing someone who who is offensive and
unpleasant and uh aggressive and and can
be violent and can be
prickly and difficult i i embrace that
it's lovely you know and i recognized it
in humans around me and also to have
some empathy for her any chance that we
get to see dottie again possibly in
season four i hope i hope dottie shows
up in paris and
does something dramatic there could be
some revenge factors
yeah yes
i hope i hope dottie shows up
yeah not to spoil too much but if there
is anybody that would be looking for joe
in season four i have a feeling it would
be definitely dottie so i'm gonna be on
that one i i'll just add this and it is
a it has been great to chat with you
today but i'm not kidding uh
this is not an easy comedy to get but
this is my circle of friends dvd that
i've had since 2000
and it because this is like a kind of
like a box office movie but also kind of
uh this is like hbo so like it was
mostly on tv so this is a hard commodity
to come by i've been a fan since then
and all the way through with all your
stuff from like the bank job and mozart
in the jungle um it was really treat to
chat with you and i've i've now forgiven
nan
for trying to steal
i'm so impressed that you have a copy of
that yes really it's actually a
difficult dvd to have and like it's one
of the old old ones um and i read that
novel too which the the movie is very
different from the novel in a lot of
ways but yeah
but it's still great so much appreciate
it
and everything comes full circle because
the one thing i remember about circle
with friends is seeing the poster
outside the movie theater i'd go as a
kid and i remember seeing the name
saffron burroughs and the name chris
o'donnell on the movie poster and chris
o'donnell and ello cool j are now in
that whatever that ncis or whatever on
cbs together so
everybody runs in the same circle of
friends eventually
very much so i'm so glad you survived
the show interesting that's that i've
been thinking about that casting putting
those two together but it's brilliant i
mean that shows like seven eight seasons
deep it's very popular and and like yeah
i it's a it's not a just you know
whatever show is a very popular show um
before you get out of here though i know
that you're a busy mom and you have a
lot of stuff going on but i also know
that you really love film in your in
your storyteller do you have any
recommendations for us for anything that
we should be watching or looking out for
well i'm a little slow to things because
my youngest is so young
so i literally just watched for example
a promising young woman which i thought
was
pretty amazing yeah um
and everything michaela cole does i
adore yeah i may destroy you is crazy i
may destroy you and um her previous work
chewing gum
and
i i did i did completely binge watch
normal people
and
ted lasso because it's so relaxing
they're so sweet my god um the idea that
masculine toxicity can be
softened at the edges and people can
learn and grow you know it seems to be
at the heart of that show and i i love
that and there's so much humor in it but
maybe if you want some more unusual
recommendations
my favorite films from the last kind of
20 years are you know
they're a little more
off-center less commercial no those are
great ones though too yeah
yeah and and i actually i got a chance
to see that movie you you were you were
into a screening last night or recently
belfast and that's great too
beautiful belfast my goodness
yes i sort of went to sleep and dreamt
about it um i have a family in belfast
and
uh but you know it's such a universal
film it's this little boy just seen
through his eyes and
he's living in a
pretty much a war zone and he's nine and
it's just his his innocence is crumbling
away it's beautiful and that kid is so
good he's so good
he's so good
i mean look that should be a nice lesson
to everybody who is a regular listener
to our show our fresh members of the
catch-up crew that even i mark ellis can
enjoy a movie the day is in black and
white and b does not have mako sharks
that are super smart so if i can do it
just about anyone
they need to have you on the poster
saying that
that is a quote ladies we should contact
we should contact kenneth branner about
that quote yes get this
all on board but you know a quote you
could retroactively put on the poster
the dvd jacket for deep blue sea is the
one the blurb from stephen king himself
because jacqueline mentioned stephen
king was a big fan stephen king this was
the first movie that stephen king saw
after he almost died he got hit by a car
going for a walk and he almost died so
stephen king's quote was my first trip
out after being smacked by a van and
almost killed was to the movies it was
deep blue sea as a matter of fact i went
in my wheelchair and loved every minute
of it so that is the master of horror
giving a big co-sign to deep blue sea as
does our expert researcher mark
hoffmeyer has a podcast about deep blue
sea so i'm so glad he got to do his
research and inform us and we got to
talk to you saffron burroughs dr susan
mcallister and deep blue sea and so many
other great roles now doing great things
behind the camera producing projects it
was a treat to have you on rotten
tomatoes it's wrong thank you so much
saffron thank you thank you so much
thank you both
[Music]
all right jacqueline that those are the
kind of interviews that you love having
because it starts at deep blue sea and
it goes to all these different places
but the bottom line is this you and me
need to find a way to go cage diving
with sharks am i right are you in uh no
will you hang out on the boat just hang
out on the boat oh absolutely if when
you get eaten i want to be able to
document it for sure absolutely
we wouldn't be friends if i wasn't there
for you in that way but no i'm not i'm
not getting in the water like what llc
says in this movie about samuel jackson
getting caught in this in the avalanche
that's the way i feel about all of this
he's just like brother what are you
doing here and i'm not going to be that
person i will be there for you in
support i've overstepped my bounds fall
simply say thank you to saffron burrows
for joining us here on this walk down
memory lane or this swim down memory
lane as it were our engineering team
here of brian perez perducy lucy herself
the entire squad at rotten tomatoes my
co-host who again
gets to speak with the greatest of all
time jacqueline coley that certainly
wasn't the case today as far as her
co-host because i am just mark ellis you
can get tickets for upcoming live shows
including dc december 16th through the
19th at mark ellis dot live that is at
that jaclyn and we are out of here we'll
see you next week everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you